[Music]
[Music]
striking news
the whole world is watching the course
of human history has changed today
the ship appears to be stopping over
johannesburg city
they're spending so much money to keep
them here when they could be spending it
on other things
at least they're keeping them separate
from us
how do your weapons work
[Applause]
we're coming to you from the entrance of
district 9 the refugee camp set up to
separate aliens from the general
population
they told me i was going to get a vest
don't worry about the vest it'll be fine
any new agents open the door please
this is an amazing fun i haven't seen
this type of setup
i don't know this has got the markings
there of uh so it's it's definitely
alien
but uh it's uh it's not a weapon
[Music]
we've seen heavily armed forces being
deployed into district 9.
nobody really knew what this place was
[Music]
find the freak
it's gonna be quick it's gonna be clean
best of all it's gonna be quiet
there's a lot of secrets in district
nine
good morning today we are talking about
romance languages
any news you want to share there's still
no signs of first contact the objects
measure at least 1500 feet tall
dr banks i'm colonel gt webber i have
something i need you to translate for me
[Applause]
is that not everyone is able to process
experiences like this
is the last time you did something
stressful does now count
we need answers as soon as possible what
do they want where are they from
yeah that just happened
what happens now
how many we're one of 12. we're a world
with no single leader
it's impossible to deal with just one of
us we need to go back in
i guess i don't need to tell you you put
yourself at risk
that's a proper introduction everything
that happens
comes down to the two of us
i know what it is what does this say
offer weapon
i don't need an interpreter to know what
this means we don't know
if they understand the difference
between a weapon and a tool
china just threatened to destroy their
shell whatever they do
france and korea will follow we could be
facing global war
we need to talk to the other side and
work together for once
we have 15 hours before this all goes to
hell
i know why they're here what the hell is
she doing
do trust me
[Music]
[Music]
is
there was a boy
[Music]
they said he wondered where
[Music]
you sure about this captain how do you
mean
i really don't know what the [ __ ] out
there
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
oh
what is that cause that's an alien bra
believe it when i landed in the wrong
play store you get the wrong
place you discovered a species here the
two unknown to
science he kicked his head in
yo check it more what them things
lovely fireworks mommy's in an invasion
of course it is
i'm killing them i'm killing them
straight let's get to the
right now i feel like going home locking
my door i'm playing fifa
what was that thinking
would invade some council state in south
london
honest looking for a fight
what is that
sorry about the driving i'm getting
listens to christmas
got one text left this is too much
madness explaining one thing
we have to call the police you'd be
better off calling the ghostbusters loss
wrong with you man you got two jesus he
looks about six
i need to get off the streets back in a
block
[Music]
wait this is safe
i'm gonna tell you a story at first
it's gonna sound ridiculous but the
longer i talk we have to find the keys
the more rational it's going to appear i
can't believe you found coffee
sugar right here hold on three
three how many times have we been here
how many times for me it's been an
[Music]
eternity
i die within five minutes of landing on
that beach
along with every other soldier
how did you do that come on come find me
when you wake up
you do know what's happening to me what
happened to you happened to me
you hijacked their power how do i
control it you have to die
every day keep coming here and i'll
train you
again again your legs broken
no i'm good then you better start over
oh come on
i'm not a soldier of course you're not
you're a weapon
they want to conquer the rest of the
world
unless you change the outcome we are not
equipped
how many times have we been here what
are you not telling me
that's gonna be dark in a few hours and
curl up by the fire and open a bottle of
wine
we should just reset whoa
[Music]
hey guys it's a girl congratulations do
you have any idea who the father is
shut up for story time
all right let's go three two one
[Music]
this is dr david jordan our mission is
to intercept a research pod from mars
16 steps to fix a shower i'm an
astronaut not a gym teacher
this is the first capsule ever to come
back from the planet we have visual
confirmation that's
it this could be a major scientific
breakthrough come on come on come on
come on come on come on
whoa
we're looking at the first proof of life
beyond earth
lowering oxygen more carbon dioxide
that's beautiful you're finally a daddy
it's gonna be a big custody battle over
this one
are you gonna bring the martian back to
earth no we're gonna keep it up here
we're gonna study where it's safe
look how fast it's growing every single
cell is a muscle cell
and a nerve cell all muscle
or brain how smart is this thing
these creatures wiped out mars millions
of years ago
if we let it get to earth we'll risk all
human life
let's kill the thing
good night moon good night roon
good night cow jumping over the moon
good night light and the red balloon
what is the primal instinct of any life
form
to survive grenade stars
we've lost all communication good night
air we'll hit the atmosphere in 39
minutes
but it could good noises everywhere
[Music]
yulia can you tell me why you decided to
help the alien
at what point did you start having
feelings for him
do i have to answer they're back again
you you're in danger
you all went too far in your research we
have to get out of here
you can come back
but she must be eliminated so this is a
cyber attack but not from this planet
you know i don't belong here dad
everything's gonna be fine
i don't even have a passport are we
gonna cross the border we'll have to
cook up a corruption scam
no more cell phones no more digital
technology
[Music]
help me
[Music]
i'm going crazy up here i can't take it
anymore tell me how much you missed me
you know how much i miss you
i can't believe it's been 20 years still
going to take your father into the
anniversary
we wouldn't be here if it wasn't for him
on this day in 1996 the world escaped
the clutches of extinction
your father was the greatest man i've
ever seen
we all lost someone we love but in their
sacrifice
we found the technology to build a
stronger
and safer earth because our survival
is only possible when we stand together
we found something out here
something only you might understand
[Music]
oh my god
how did they get the light sir
we didn't
it happened on its own two days ago
20 years ago when we destroyed the
mothership we detected a burst and an
x-band frequency
directed toward deep space
[Music]
looks like someone picked up the phone
and answered
a distress call
they're coming back that's definitely
bigger than the last one
it has some gravity
what goes up must come down
shouldn't we be nervous um yeah
why are they screaming they're not
screaming
they're celebrating we could use our
isolation chamber that contains their
telepathy
where's my dad did he get in here
soldier about it there he overrode the
system sir please unlock the door
don't you worry about me just get as
many answers as you can
who is she our whole lives
built up to this moment it's touched
down over the atlantic which park
all of it make them pay not going up
there to make friends
we've got to remind them earth is not
we never had a chance we didn't last
time either
we convinced an entire generation that
this is a battle that we could win
we sacrifice for each other no matter
what the cost and that's worth fighting
for
it's fourth of july so let's show them
some fireworks
they'd like to get the landmarks
[Music]
[Music]
no no
[Music]
yes
come to me
[Music]
when was the last time you touched
someone
[Music]
you don't want to wake up do you
i'm eddie brock i'm a reporter
i always seem to find myself questioning
something the government may not be
looking at
i found something really bad
and i have been
he's a better backer taken
look around in the world what do you see
a planet on the brink of collapse human
beings
are disposable but man and symbiote
combined this is the new race new
species
a higher life form
what do you want from me
you'll find out i'm so sorry
we cannot just hurt people
[Music]
eyes
[Music]
it's not completely awful you have no
idea how much you're scaring me right
now
eddie cooperate
and you just might survive
guys you do not want to do this trust me
giant leaps will always come
at a cost
[Music]
we are
oh i have a parasite
yeah name is chant
you jake sully
i'd like to talk to you about a fresh
start on a new world
you'll be making a difference
i became a marine for the hardship i
told myself i can pass any test a man
can pass
all i ever wanted was a single thing
worth fighting for
ladies and gentlemen
you're not in kansas anymore you're on
pandora
you should see your faces not there
beyond that fence
we have an indigenous population called
the navi
this is why we're here because this
little gray rock sells for 20 million a
kilo
their village happens to be resting on
the richest deposit and they need to
relocate
and you're supposed to be finding a
diplomatic solution
the concept is to drive these remotely
controlled bodies called avatars
they're grown from human dna mixed with
dna of the natives marine in an avatar
body
that's a potent mix you get me what i
need i'll see two get your legs back
your real legs yes sir looks like you
this is your avatar just relax and let
your mind go blank
it shouldn't be hard for you
jake it's real simple
i want you to learn from the inside i
want you to gain their trust
you should not be here go back
all this is your fault
i need your help
[Music]
outstanding
i haven't gotten lost in the woods have
you you forget what team you're playing
for
strong pray on the week and nobody does
a thing
you've got one hour you knew this would
happen
everything jake it's crazy here
before rich is taking over he's rolling
well i guess we better stop him
they've sent us a message that they can
take whatever they want
but we will send them a message
and this this is our land
[Music]
maybe we have a word let me guess he's
done something crazy
show me again i'm going to break your
neck
welcome to the bus nebraska williams
that's coil that's lynch with mercs
why are you here i don't think you
believe me
come on i had it running with a space in
here
this [ __ ] guy is crazier than the
rest of us
the [ __ ] was that that's the thing that
killed my man
[Music]
seems to enjoy it that's not a predator
that's a sports hunter well we took a
vote predator's cooler right
[ __ ] yeah do you have a plan
x sniper with ptsd and a team that's
mental you're insane right
gentlemen they're large they're fast
and [ __ ] you up their idea of tourism
figured something out i think we're
gonna die
just pointing it out a big boy's a
hunter
he brought his dogs with him
the predator
only in theaters september 14th
[Music]